dave what was the tipping point for you
to leave california like if you were to
say
well the tipping point was five years
ago but i finally made a decision today
or was it like covet i'm done i'm sick
of it let's start looking at different
places and then you looked at tennessee
texas and florida and you said i'm gonna
go to florida yeah so i moved to la in
2013. uh we had about a thousand bucks
from new york
from new york so i'm a true new yorker
born in brooklyn grew up in long island
i went to suny binghamton i lived in
manhattan most of my life so really the
only two places as an adult that i've
lived until these last three months were
new york city and la and yet the ideas
that i talk about are the stuff that
people care about in the middle of the
country so i don't know what happened i
don't know what happened i had these two
coasts and somehow my ideas kind of kind
of came to them when you moved from new
york to la did you come with that new
york you know coastal ideology to oh
yeah i was i was a lefty i worked i
worked for the young turks i was a
bernie supporter all of that all that
all that stuff it's all it's true all of
it as uh solo said yeah it was all true
um but there were a couple moments i
mean look the the two years of covet
demolished los angeles los angeles is a
shell of itself hollywood has been
destroyed okay so i could do all the
basic stuff the crime the homelessness
is the drug
i'll tell you what the final moment was
the final straw and i had been thinking
about it for about a year
back and forth could i do it where was i
going to go nashville
dallas etc
i campaigned with larry elder for the
for the recall so i was opening on stage
with him and tor you know going out
there and meeting people and it was
amazing it was incredible you know they
called him the black face of white
supremacy that's what the l.a sometimes
article yeah the title felt like an
onion headline by the way or a babylon
onion isn't even that good
young woman who threw an egg at him in
the gorilla mask that always i thought
somehow the media didn't pick that one
up you know it's like it was just
extraordinary anyway i'm out there with
this guy and there was such energy i met
so many good people they were not far
right they weren't even conservatives
most of them were liberals they were
california liberals who were mugged by
reality they were just good decent
people who suddenly their restaurants
were closed their kids were locked down
all of this stuff anyway the recall
obviously was a disaster
and three days after the recall you want
the exact moment your head is your mind
is going to explode three days after the
recall i got audited by the state
[Laughter]
that makes sense yeah and i said we have
you've never been audited before i've
never been audited before my my stuff's
all clean
we take very good care of all my
businesses um three days after got that
immediately
like literally i think i hung up the
phone and i called my real estate agent
i said get me out of here and we put the
we did that house privately
i was told it in three weeks basically
and then i had to really quickly figure
out i always felt that it was going to
be florida uh but you know i love the
the blaze guys and i do some stuff with
them and glenn beck and glenn really
wanted me in dallas so i had a little
moment of that i loved the daily wire
guys and candace and ben and so i did
look at one house in nashville but i'm
so happy to be here and i'm
i'm i'm really like as i said i'm reborn
here i feel you feel it here in florida
it's free and you're saying you said
something prior to shooting you said i
love florida i don't know you could
curse if you want yeah there was an f in
there yeah no i i love florida it's it's
not just
it's not just the the politics of it
that that's good it's what it's doing to
the people
uh you know i don't know when the last
time you guys just went back to new york
or went to cali or just went to some of
these blue cities he's from cali yeah
yeah no i know so but i don't know have
you been there just in the last couple
months like
i went to la
to shoot a prageru video about a month
ago i said to my guys i will fly in go
to the studio and get me the hell out of
there even though the prageru studio is
a half mile from my house i guess it
would have been nice to go look at it
again or something it was a disaster i
got asked for a vaccine passport to go
to coffee bean and tea leaf
uh that makes sense just everything
about it it's rotten and then even just
the greenery the greenery in florida is
beautiful and wonderful in the trees and
then you go to la and everything's dying
and dead and brown it's uh
what the hell am i being clear about
this yeah i'm very happy here and i
don't like that place by the way what
was the reason why you chose florida
over dallas and nashville you know it's
partly i think because of my well first
off i have some family here and we
hadn't had been in a state with family
for a long time most i'm from new york
as i said so most of my family's east
coast my folks have a place in florida
my sister lives in miami with her
husband and kids
also because of the tech side of things
obviously miami is just exploding right
now in the tech world so i wanted to be
close to that but at a political level
you know for me as someone that came
from the left and you know i have mostly
libertarian views but i don't mind con
calling myself a conservative now
there's a wide thing right right now
happening on the right you know you got
the disaffected lefties and the
libertarians then you've got the you
know sort of evangelical or the
christian conservatives there really is
this movement of trying to figure out
can this thing really hold because there
are a lot of people that have different
beliefs serious beliefs that are very
different i felt the stuff that i care
about the most it's working here in
florida meaning it's a little more of a
secular conservatism as opposed to you
go to nashville or you go to texas it's
a little more religious that's not
necessarily my thing i felt that the
ideas that i really care about can
flourish a little bit more here so it
was it was a series of things you know
the weather is good and all that